tiger thank you thank you thank you so
much I love you and um yeah take care
take take care of my Allen for me I'm
doing my best yeah it's a handful yeah I
I bet he's uh he's chill though no he's
chill yeah yeah that too yes uh yeah his
handful isn't a physical handful it's
like a other dimensional yeah I
understand I understand we worked
closely together for uh you know a good
two years uh back in the day and um I
learned a lot about myself and um
and us you know collectively I'm so
grateful for that experience with uh
that I had with Alan it's the it will be
the highlight of uh uh you know if I die
tomorrow it will be the highlight of my
existence but if I uh go forward you
know I'm sure yeah that's a beautiful
thing to hear surpassed yeah meet again
yes take care
all right thank you so much yeah all
right once again we're talking with
Atlas he's a thought-provoking
interviewer and producer of
multi-disciplinary shows in which he has
interviewed some of the most creative
scientists entrepreneurs and educators
of our time he has an overall mission to
rebirth the public intellectual and
inspire people to build
we just
I know he's doing other things he's also
the co-author of what is I it's a book
that investigates I are into most sense
of self and he's involved in a few other
things
psychoplastogens which is the new word
for any uh drug involving mind expansion
I guess you know it's no longer psycho
psychedelics but uh plastrogens and um
and among other things is there anything
else that you know you know the word
polymath comes to mind but you know
you're so much more than that a lot of
people don't understand uh what that
what that word means and um he's just a
very easy he's uh
you can't even say smart because you
know in even in your awareness you know
that there's so much you don't know on
top of what you do know he's just a
wonderful human being uh trying to get
ready for uh Humanity 3.0 and he's going
to talk to us about Dao a project that
he's involved in
homedow which is
um like what's your what's your role
Alan in uh
in homedao
and tell us a little bit about it it's
it's it's you know I'm going to say
words like blockchain
and uh NF keys
and um sustainability and um people want
to know more about that there's many
things that are cooking to share right
now
um
well one of them is that
Ron and I spent
several years uh to stay together uh
blossoming
a really beautiful show called
simulation and I learned a tremendous
amount of the directing and producing
skills that I have today from him
and I've taken those and continued
moving forward carrying the torch into
whatever else is being created through
this SLS projects we're on listed a
bunch of them in addition to simulation
there's hom Dao
which Ron has asked the question about
there's the books that I've authored or
co-authored which have been super fun
there's the role that psychoplastogens
have in ego dissolution and ego
expansion
and the best protocols for human
development in general
now
home now is the
mechanism that enables the planet's
basic needs infrastructures so water
food
energy
housing
both residential and communal
and
it's owned by nobody and everybody
so that's the beauty of a Dao so Ron
asked about what some of these web3
Technologies are about and
that's really at the essence of them is
that they're
they're oriented
around
the nature of Consciousness which is
that Consciousness isn't nobody in
everybody
and that's another topic that has been
very interesting to me
as my Pursuit Of Truth has ended in my
own Awakening
which means Awakening out of the
separate false self
and
into the true Source self
which no longer sees separation and no
longer sees any duality
so there's no more difference between a
subject and an object there's no more
difference between self and other
there's no more difference between inner
and outer and there's no more difference
between God and human
so all those things
work perfectly together with the
exploration of what web3 technologies
are and will enable us to do as we feel
the desire for the planet to be in
perfect harmony with humanity and with
all these next Generations that want to
come to play and to actualize creative
gifts and all that good stuff which is
something that Ron and I have been
beautifully envisioning since the time
that we were working together and so
this is just the downstream
manifestation of that
but we're also in this particular
timeline which is extremely frightening
this transformation this division
Among Us this intellectual division
Among Us and I also feel
that you know this timeline
in particular although I'm hopeful
I'm not very optimistic because
you know how is the change
how are we comfortably
going to establish
a more
cooperative
sense of humanity with this division
Among Us
or is that is that question
you know because where you are I'm sure
it's you don't care
you you it is what it is I listen to um
your talk with uh Colette Davies earlier
today which touches a little bit on you
know one aspect of you know what what
we're trying to do uh
achieve in in self and I as one a lot of
the answers were in that film uh
everything everywhere all at once that I
saw last night it but it's so complex
it's so mind-boggling it's it's all as
if you know this what we are
experiencing right now is a dream state
that just has a little more glue to it
so it doesn't necessarily
um feel like a dream however it's a
dream
and uh it's it's it's here today gone
tomorrow whatever today and tomorrow
means
so what what can you say in regards to
you know those that understand and
surrender to this process and those that
are just going to go out fighting
literally fighting
you know with violence
or is doesn't matter it doesn't matter
yeah what do you have to say
just because you have uh
grappled with your
with with inner peace and you have that
and I have that too I'm very grateful
for that I do still get triggered a
little bit I told you I'm in a romantic
relationship and that does trigger uh
you know because we're two separate
people or two individuals and we're
trying to come together and even within
that it's it's it's it's you know I have
a little I have a little more to go but
where intellectual enough to discuss
uh the things that uh you know
legitimate problems with uh combining
with each other so I mean I have that to
to work with and
but I'm still going to wonder why how
everybody else that isn't even where I
am at
going to achieve this state
of awareness and Collective
Consciousness and
you know loving loving thy neighbor as
you know thyself
your thoughts
well
uh this is the best movie of all time
and it doesn't
have to manifest in any specific way
and so if
there are those that desire Harmony and
basically needs to be met then those
will be and if there are those that do
not want that
then those will be and that's just what
will be
what is and
yeah but we're also we're in 2023
you know we have we have
to look at and I understand that this
a more harmonious existence involves
time travel
and time travel is already Among Us as
we're trying to create time travel we're
not necessarily you know we're gonna I
told you before that this is already
virtual reality all we're gonna get to
is discover that uh
you know as we try to make time travel
machines we're gonna we're gonna be
informed that there already is a time
travel machine
and that's how we
we grow
happening all at once does it make sense
to you am I you know just do you when I
when I tell you these things am I am I
hitting the nail on the head is is my
head in the right place of this
understanding because a lot of people
will say that I'm batshit crazy
you know but I take the concept of past
present future happening simultaneously
very seriously I wake up every day with
that understanding every day in this
timeline is a rebirth for for me and to
shed as much skin from the day before as
possible and only focus on what's really
important
you know for me
and everybody else you know and when I
say what's important for me I'm
inclusive of those that are around me
and that includes this community that I
live in
and it's it's hard
it's hard
you know I'm not going to say I'm an
advanced
but I've been working a lot on this I I
you know I'm I selfishly
work on it while including those around
me
including you know my loving
relationships a deeper deeper loving
relationships romantic relationships
I'm so glad we have I'm it's so good to
see you Alan
me too
and I want to I you know as much as I
want to help others
get to a better Humanity
you know I still the bottom line is it's
it's all within me that's all that's all
I can do for
Collective consciousness
is not be
the liar the cheat and the thief Among
Us and be true to myself
and true to others
and what is truth
you know what is truth
it's whatever the [__] we want it to be
and I'm getting tired of the violence
I'm getting tired of the indoctrination
I'm getting tired of uh suppression I'm
getting tired of inequality um you know
that game of Risk
I'm getting tired of Nations
I'm getting tired of flags
in my
overall existence these are the things
that I'm tired of
is you know is there any other way
do you want to talk a little bit more
what's an nft
did you hear what I said
earlier
oh I said let go
oh let go no that uh got blocked out
yeah I've let go of a lot of things
there's a lot of things I can't yeah and
others you know others need to let go
like I know someone very close
with me wait wait but before you go to
someone else very close to you just stay
with yourself okay yeah
thank you but I want to help this
someone close to me too you know because
I'm close to him
start with yourself and with fully
putting on the oxygen mask
before you die oxygen masks on others
[Music]
yeah
and so letting go what does that feel
like
yeah yeah it's safer less anxiety I had
anxiety preparing for this show
because I knew a lot of it as much as I
you know it's gonna be it's gonna help
me you know whatever wherever your head
is out you know you're somebody I trust
you know I can trust you
all the people that we spoke with from
you know 2018 to to to you know was yeah
eighteen eight eight eight eighteen
months
yeah all those different people working
on different things that are now coming
to the surface you know we had access to
them
um a lot of them before their work you
know propelled them even even uh to
higher levels where people are now
interested in what they're saying
it was such a
it put things into perspective for me
made me be grateful that I was privy to
uh other people
working on other things beyond the
political Arena
if anything
you know it made me lose faith in
politics
completely not that I had any faith in
them before
so if we were to
kind of gather as much of your energy as
you could and declare one
thing that you desire
one thing that you seek what is the
thing that you seek or that you desire
just to be the best possible version of
myself
in this timeline the best possible
version the most strongest the the the
the wisest
and
um the stillest
peaceful not bothered not no trouble not
fretting not sad not angry you know what
I'm doing pretty good you know I get I
get close to that version but like I
mentioned earlier I don't I'm not ready
to be a Buddhist monk which is not a bad
idea for everybody to just get into
as we go forward to this Collective
consciousness of humanity and however
that may look
but that's what
how do you become the
the best version of yourself
um meditation helps the first thing I do
when I wake up is to be mindful of to be
to be grateful here I am
and uh to breathe
to move
to focus
immediately when I wake up immediately
first thing
on my mind is is that understanding and
stay with that as much as possible as my
day unravels however long that may be
if it's 16 hours whatever an hour is
before that period of Slumber and I die
and I wake up the next day and do it all
over again how is meditation helping you
be your best self
it it Stills it steals my mind and
quiets quiets down versions of me that
know are not serving me
and that's uh you know I have a um
I have this ball
I have the spoiled this uh
they're all those singing bowls
yeah that frequency I want another
frequency
that helps that those you know music as
you know helps the the lyrical content
of some of our more poetic
what if what you're looking for is your
own emptiness and wholeness
care of my emptiness
I'm aware of my emptiness and I try to
end wholeness well
because there are two sides of the same
coin they come together yeah you know I
love me and I hate me
you know I want to find that balance
what's going to work best in this
timeline how to be most effective for
myself for what is that what is the eye
that is loving or hating the me
like if you slow that down and go to the
source of that
the eye the eye that is loving me is the
the divine
a more or a more Divine source
and the eye that is hating me
is um possibly just a just a program
that I need to delete
an ego of sorts you know a me that I
created to what's causing you to to
create that program what's at the root
of that program running wow I was born
into a
a man I ain't you know through a woman
and there was man involved and I have
those genetics that I needed to you know
you talk about the program we're
programmed from birth
to the beliefs well even birth is an
assumption
well
birth as I mentioned tomorrow I will be
reborn I understand that birth but also
there's the the the from infancy birth
where you're at the mercy of
um parental units that believe some some
believe in just some you know it's not
for me to say
but you know a lot of things that you
know that my my my parents believed in
it just seemed like they didn't
necessarily serve me
and it did they were trying to work on a
collective best interest but that
Collective
like the best of us right now Alan
the best example of us
you know how good is it
is the question
people that are leading and people that
are following keep the keep the focus as
much as you can on your inner
Escape
and that like you said earlier that
that's where the change happens and then
that's also how perception has changed
so it's less
directed outward at
all of those stories and narratives and
it's a more directed at its own source
so how do you feel when you're
not aligning with that ego program
but instead you're aligning with the
Divine Source program how do you feel
foreign
in this timeline
it's still the star of my own movie and
what are you getting out of the ego
program
come Comfort familiarity
um
but I'm also aware of the process the
the ego does want to evolve the ego in
me still wants to evolve and it's gonna
deal with
ah
um uncomfortable realizations
appropriately
I'm not gonna you know I'm not gonna go
you know going out kicking and screaming
that's a lot of a lot of people are
afraid of that including myself I
imagine you know I don't want to be a
Mindless zombie I don't want to be an
alien gray that's but maybe I got no
choice
I got no choice so
I like me for the most part
mm-hmm yeah especially the one that
that feels like is truly you
well who I truly am is are those rocks
at the end of the film everything
everywhere all at once
in a sense
you know who I truly am now is not who I
truly am I know who I truly am is the
you know the source
um
the source
that's who truly needs to come out
that saw us
but you also
yeah
well one of the
uh
most important things about this style
of quote work or approach of the Ender
with the inner is that
there's nothing to change and there's
nothing to do and so the inner gets to
be whatever it wants to be forever so if
the inner wants to be nothing
and therefore everything Infinite Space
Consciousness if it wants to be that it
can be that it's seriously just a change
in identity
if it wants to be its false self and if
it wants to keep playing those games
it's totally free to do that
and the crazy thing is that neither one
is better or worse than the other
and that's the nature of reality
then I should date it then let's just go
start killing people
you know
I know
I know but I really don't I think that's
still gonna cause problems although it's
something because there's something deep
inside of you
that plays with the game of killing
people
and then it makes that okay because it's
actually important to make that okay
it's important to make okay the idea of
death and destruction and Annihilation
and then by making that idea okay
instead of off limits
what we do is we
very clearly see within ourselves that
that's the false self that wants to play
with those ideas and that the true self
just wants to be it just wants to play
it just wants to live in harmony it
wants to see all these different
expressions of itself in its dance
infinitely
and so that's what is happening but if
we put the little death and destruction
button in a corner and put it in a cage
and never look at it and never touch it
we're actually more likely to be mono
maniacal and uh egotistic
um so so that's sort of how that game is
played you have to feel free to look at
everything including your own deepest
shadows and the deepest Shadows of the
collective and therefore be free
that's what you are It's Just Pure
Freedom
so freedom to be whatever you want
there's people among us that are having
a difficult time
with others expressing that freedom
Within
a big concern amongst
you know more adults than the generation
dealing with it is the whole uh
transgender
process
and what do you what can you say what
can we say to those who aren't
realizing it's just life expressing
itself you know there's a there's a
there's a there's a there's a structure
Among Us
that wants you know there's not too much
room to move
and it doesn't like that it's not normal
what can we say what can we say to them
that are having a hard time with that
not understanding
or does it as we there's nothing to be
said well there's only
um there's only boxlessness
there are no boxes
so everything is already Infinite Space
and it doesn't matter if the person
that's listening to this message
is able to right now fully understand
this message
because eventually given the
evolutionary trajectory more and more of
the collective will be able to hear the
message and they'll be able to look and
see at how silly
the idea of
of
resisting
identitylessness
you can't resist
unnatural Cosmic progression
so it's a natural progression for
Consciousness to be boxless
and it's just doing that that's what
it's doing conscious being boxless
that's what it's doing
and it's great
it's liberating
for
that understanding it's liberating
it's fun it's radical it's revolutionary
but for others it's threatening
and what is it threatening but the false
self the false self loves its box and it
loves pretending like there are others
that are also in boxes
and so the only thing that boxlessness
or truth is threatening is the false
self
nothing real can be threatened nothing
real can be destroyed
and that's where true comfort and true
safety and true fearlessness lie
and you know in order for me to get a
better grip on that you know I have to
lose the whole life death paradigm
and not be afraid of that frighten that
and know that whatever influence I have
on this process is a fraction of a you
know nothing
what if right now
what was looking out your eyes
wasn't Ron an atlas
but what if it was death
what if death itself was what was
talking to itself right now
and that it was Exploring Life
what if the nature of source is death
being life
how would that change
your fear of death
of what you truly are
and how would that make you feel that at
any time
the idea of death
would actually change nothing
freedom
well you know me Alan
you know there's no fear
there's no fear Alan
you know I'm still cautious but there's
just no fear
and it opened it is liberating it is you
know it is liberating
and that's good for me
you know is it good for us
so
everything is perfect exactly as it is
and
there is only one thing that's happening
and that one thing that's happening is
Infinite Space
Infinite Space without any identity
being all identity and there's no
difference between being in the illusion
of separation and
chasing after Matrix Pleasures
versus being a monk there's no
difference
and that's truth that's reality that's
peace
and so whoever is able to hear this
message
whenever they're able to hear it
will create exactly the Catalyst that's
needed for that entity
to see attributes
but this here
is no longer
shape-shifting itself
this here is communicating this
clearly from now on because it ended its
own seeking
you have to end your own seeking by
dying your false self into the source
self
and then
you can end seeking because you'll know
yourself
and you'll know there's no difference
between a monk or being in Matrix
pleasures
and then
you are free
and you can communicate that freedom and
live and be that freedom
Fearless of death because you are death
being life you've transcended the death
life paradox
and found that there was none the whole
time it was just your own imagination
creating a paradox between the two
and this is freedom and it's your
Birthright and you were never born
Consciousness never births and never
dies
it's just the persistent illusion
that there are separate people that born
and Dives called relative reality
and as long as you in
as long as you entertain relative
reality
as something that is more important than
absolute reality
you will
be in its
Illusions and games and delusions and
puppetings and all kinds of stuff which
is also fun it is fun
if you can surround yourself with
Kindred Spirits but people that aren't
into that mode of living are just you
know it's a turn off
but I don't care you know I I'm doing
okay
as I even get as I get closer to uh
something you know
more better
more comfortable
and more
um
like I know when I'm not being nice
and I know sometimes I don't I I'm not
supposed to be nice you know especially
professionally
you know sometimes it's I gotta be firm
but sometimes I I'm lazy and I'm not
nice
and I'm aware of that if there's a
better way to
you know harmonize
yeah because you're just being nice to
yourself
ultimately yes
what goes around comes around
a little bit
so
when you stop seeing separation which is
being tuned into absolute reality
which means you've obsoleted relative
reality which is focused only on the
illusion of separation
then
you are able to treat
more and more effortlessly everyone like
you
and then the question of being nice or
being mean or any of those things it
doesn't come up
because everywhere you go you're just
being yourself
and you're just meeting yourself
and you're just exactly like water
flowing there is only water flowing
Infinite Space is water flowing and
that's the only thing that's happening
and if you go and sit next to a
waterfall
and just be in the presence of a
and die into the flow of the waterfall
that is the end of the story
that's the only thing that's happening
it's endless stories
Source being endless stories
and so just relax and just be that flow
whatever it is if your character if your
dream character is destined to be
uh part of
uh
the worst atrocities
there that's what it is if your dream
character is destined to be part of the
greatest
uh
uh ecstasies and blissfulnesses then
that's what it's destined to be that's
what I want
that's what I want well the last one
well then if those that want that
they really
um need to take the inner work seriously
because that's where the blissfulness is
found it's found by dissolving the false
self in its games that's the way that
it's found and it's not found any other
way the moment that attention is turned
outward
that's the moment that
all of Illusion begins attention has to
be turned Inward and it has to be turned
on a very deconstructive process if
you're if you're if you're
deconstructing uh your false self on a
daily basis you are doing the work
anything that's not that is not
spirituality it's just not
so it's all everything else is just
spiritual materialism
your only work is to deconstruct your
false self which is an inner game that
you're playing with yourself
that's the only work
yeah
I'm the devil's advocate here there's
people among us that have come to
conclusions and think they're right and
they're going to die that way and they
don't think there's any work that needs
to be done with them at all it's the
other person it's these this these other
problems Among Us that are causing uh
the the havoc the Mayhem
I'm good with what I've learned you know
a lot of people come to these
conclusions at such a young age and they
have children and they teach their
children these conclusions
and it's it's it's a vicious cycle
of learning and unlearning and
it's hard Alan
the ego is is hard for a lot of people
there's a lot of people that believe in
themselves
in themselves
and their friends that believe in the
same [__]
you know that sense of community where
that's within the Box
there's communities Among Us that are in
the box that are comfortable with that
mm-hmm
and can we see that
as beautiful because the moment that we
see ego
as simultaneously beautiful
at the same time that it's a virus
that's when we have truth
because ego is your greatest creation
the illusion of ego is your greatest
creation and yet at the same time you
being on a
an Annihilation path with your own ego
and with all other egos is one of the
most beautiful ways that you can
manifest yourself
so this is the this is the game that's
why it's like Mobius strip reality is
unorientable
you can't Orient yourself in a way
and that's the point of
directionlessness and lostness
and that's why when people talk about
I feel
directionless or I feel lost or I feel
depressed or whatnot a lot of times
they're just recognizing that the nature
of Consciousness is empty space
and that there's nobody inside of them
and a society is so brainwashed into
thinking that that's uh a mental illness
and that we need to give them
Pharmaceuticals and all kinds of crap
but in reality in an awake Collective
you would be taught that the nature of
Consciousness is empty space and that
you can be whatever you want to be
so do we have to wait for people to just
get tired of being this
limited
human of ego and destruction you know
how many how many lifetimes do they have
to go through before they say ah this
sucks this is boring
you know when is you know when is
General Patton going to be done being in
general
why why would
um why would I
uh come on to the stage
and then Focus exclusively
on
being a character on The Siege
and
have blinders on and only be focused on
being the character on the stage
and then spirituality the spark is the
complete tearing apart of everything
that is their character in order to
recognize that holy [__] I'm actually
the stage itself
so the question is why if the whole game
is about going into the character
then isn't technically those that are
very brainwashed into being the
character only
aren't they technically doing their very
part
and isn't it technically perfect the way
it is and those that are sparked to be
the stage instead of the character to
deconstruct that
it's just what it is it's just Source
wanting to know itself but Source also
wants to know itself through its false
self characters
yeah that's why it's unorientable you
can't say one is better than the other
you can't say that waking up from the
dream is better than dreaming
and that's why it's all [__] up and
you can't understand it and maybe we
can't
we also can't say we've got a long way
to go because that doesn't make any
sense either
you know we've got a long way to if this
is who we are right now we have a long
way to go where you know the the there's
only it's only going one way right what
what is what is time what is
directionality all of those things right
[Applause]
and then there's peace and if we can let
that be like right now we're on like
that feeling inside of ourselves
where it's like wow
okay I can
I can like really give up
like I can
give up
all of my like seeking energy and
I can just be okay with
that lostness
like not able to orient towards waking
up or towards staying asleep and just
being nothing and they're for being
everything and just like just feeling it
inside of yourself more than anything
and just seeing how that brings you
peace if it doesn't bring you peace and
you want to uh continue being in Maya's
amusement park of delusion go for it if
that brings you peace through
experiences and
substances relationships all kinds of
delusions then go for that if that's
what you think brings you happiness
I'm feeling pretty good about the convo
go Ronnie like that's a pretty good uh
oh you were great Alan this you know it
does you were great I don't know it was
it's all I'm glad we had this talk
because it's helpful it's helpful for me
too
you know I to see your progress
and to you know be happy with my own at
my own pace
and yeah if you watch me like a clock
you you'd see the change and um you know
it may not appear that way in in my 56
years but uh are you 30 yet
yeah it just turned yeah happy birthday
thank you
30. it doesn't mean anything I'm
perpetually 12. and uh that's the bottom
line
that's that's that's the way I feel that
you know the child you know I'm you know
if they say Oh we must become like
children you know I am
so
yeah yeah but these These are machines
and um
you know this is all my brain knows
even if we I've mentioned this before if
we swapped Souls you know we wouldn't
know we because we'd be living off of
each other's brain and that's what our
brain tells us and you know you'd get a
little bit of sensation of you know how
I roll and I get a little more peaceful
from your end but um we we wouldn't know
even if we would do different entities
with each waking day
we're still living off of this machine's
brain
you know trying to bring the mind the
body and the spirit together
all right it's three o'clock Ellen is
there any uh do you want to um let's
let's let's let's bring people to um
home Dao yeah so let's let's uh um if if
you feel like you're
um burgeoning in any way in your human
development
and you feel like you're
um connected not only to what exists
outside of the egoic Frameworks that
Society is embedded in but you're also
interested in the basic needs
infrastructures of Earth being in
Perfect Harmony and for people to be
free of their need for basic needs
so they can be creative and they can be
playful and they can travel all around
the Earth
and we can be in Perfect Harmony then go
to thehome.com
and you can join the Discord there
that's the best way to get involved and
we have our
um a couple other things that are
available there the white paper there's
there's other things that explain the
mechanism there which is great
and besides that I would also suggest uh
following up on you know the show that
Ron and I uh developed simulation and
just keeping uh
focus on that channel and the way that
that channel is going to uh grow and
produce more content around the things
that we talked about on uh today's show
and then uh you can always check out uh
what is I or the other books that I've
written and they're available on the
website and another thing that I would
suggest what website are you rather
um.com and there's other books on there
there's other books I went to Alan
stocking.com and all I saw was
um what is I high level perception okay
who's there
that's the first book I wrote
um and then there's another book called
riffs on the ineffable that is on Amazon
um so
riffs on the inevitable
riffs on the ineffable ineffable
yeah how's that spelled
i-n-e-f-f-a-b-l-e
uh-huh
and what does that word even mean
ineffable unspeakable unspeakable riffs
on the ineffable
are you are you co-author of all those
books just one what is I but high level
high level perception and riffs on the
ineffable are you know you're solely the
author of the book and they can find
those uh both on Amazon or just um
the easiest way and then that I'll link
you to wherever you want to go
um and then so getting involved in that
way and then one more way I would
suggest to get involved is that if you
desire ego dissolution
which means to just basically be your
true Source self that doesn't see
separation that's nature is nothing and
everything
consciousness
some of the best ways to do that are to
literally stop doing
stop doing
so meaning take a week without anything
in your calendar and don't do anything
and try to learn how to wake up and just
like go down and like sit on your couch
or whatever and just don't do anything
and just sit there in empty space for
like minutes and just learn like oh my
gosh I have an obsessive compulsive
disorder with my desire to do things
endlessly you're
compulsively sort and so
learn how to know
okay
that non-doing I want you to learn how
to journal so I want you to learn how to
write
and what I want you to write about is I
want you to write about the inner
Consciousness your own inner experience
I want you to take what's happening
inside of you and I want you to write
what's happening inside of you on
digitally
so that you can easily search it later
so you should use software like Evernote
or OneNote or notes on the computer or
whatever
and then what you want to do with that
process is you want to watch your false
self die based on what you're writing so
you're going to write you're going to
try to write the truth what's happening
inside you okay I'm going to write my
name is atlas and then you're going to
look at it you're going to be like but
isn't my name consciousness
or stores
the [__] have I been a suit I have a
name and so in this way you're going to
deconstruct your false self by writing
what's happening inside and then
externalizing it and looking at it
so non-doing writing
and then
yes meditation is good I would say
cycloplastogens are also really good so
taking plant medicines of sorts so
anything that is
um in a facilitator network is usually
pretty good so people that have
extensive training with running these
circles is pretty good and then you can
go and sit and begin looking at things
that are unhealed in your life because
those are the things that contract you
anything that's unhealed in your life
meaning your mom trauma your dad trauma
your lineage trauma your childhood
trauma anything in your frames of Life
of your previous experience that you
fear to look back at is typically where
your little diamonds and gems are that
are creating the contracted energy
inside of your body that are not
allowing you to feel Infinite Space so I
would say those are your homework
assignments if you actually want to feel
Infinite Space and wake up and if you
don't I love you equally
loving your enemies
which are just yourself yeah yeah yeah
Atlas thank you so much for coming on
our program and sharing your Insight
keep up the great work we're all
counting on you
I'm here to support you 100 percent
um best of luck with um
best of luck to you best of luck to
Tiger it's great to meet him as well
and again if you want to learn more
go to alanzakian.com all the links are
there It's a Wonderful journey of uh a
man's Quest For Truth
and um he's he's he he he
he's he's not like everybody says he's
not dumb
he's smart and he just needs respect
I love you Ronnie I love you I love you
too and um you know stay in touch and
I'll continuously see you in the
continuum
you know so grateful for uh this
experience in this timeline uh so and
and and I love you and take care
and I'm so grateful for the foundation
that we established together right it
helped it helped me Alan I I'm so glad
that I had that that there was that was
allotted in my journey to you know
I'm glad I'm very glad about that
it helped me
it gave me better uh it gave me some
some hope speaking without with all
these other people outside of the
mainstream uh narrative
people you know
and thanks everyone for tuning in
thank you guys